[Music]
what's shaking reject nation is I John
Humphrey doing Greg's favorite intro for
my videos and with me as always and even
when I'm not here
is Greg Anna what's up guys happy to be
a guest on the real rejects
thanks for joining me man we're gonna
review how to treat Dragon three the
hidden world we saw this last night at
RealD 3d huge thanks to them for a
hooking us up actually if you do see the
movie try to catch it in 3d because the
3d is actually pretty gorgeous pretty
beautiful Ryan the guy who puts
everything together for the events for
RealD 3d he had this tip before we
watched the movie they said to the crowd
of try to look past the screen and I
wasn't even sure what the hell he meant
by that like what he's just imagine yeah
and that instead of just use that note
to see what he was talking about and
throughout most of this movie you really
do notice oh wow there's a lot that's
really popping out of you because
there's also a lot of frames of like the
cameras just moving forward and then
suddenly something will come in from
behind and in front of the camera oh
yeah and a lot of those shots especially
there's a lot of those kind of
directional angles and yeah there's like
cameras moving forward or something
appears like really deep focus and stuff
and there are a lot of things like water
and clouds that really enhance that
effect so yeah it is really worth it in
3d easily a 3d experience definitely
lends itself to a 3d experience which I
mean this franchise over I've never been
a huge 3d guy but this franchise overall
has you know top-notch 3d so before we
hop into the full-on review though I
just want to give a quick shout out to
everyone who's joining us on the
Stardust app much appreciated it's free
to download free to use we have a lot of
fun over there recording 30-second
reactions reviews sometimes even micro
sketches for all the latest trailers and
films TV shows even stuff we don't cover
on the normal channel so if you're a
movie fan at all I think you'd really
enjoy it we'd love it if you come over
there join us special link in the
description box so you can download it
and don't forget to follow us first
because that's how they know we sent you
and without further ado let's talk about
how to
dragon 3 and I guess I will take it away
cuz I maybe feel a little more for this
movie than you did but I think I hate
this movie yeah I never want to know
that yeah worst franchise ever and I
don't care about it it's all we're just
reading the IMDB description sure when
hiccup discovers toothless isn't the
only Night Fury he must seek the hidden
world a secret dragon utopia before a
hired tyrant named grimille finds it
first and we can't use footage because
even if there's no audio and only like a
second this video is a potential to be
blocked worldwide so you might see some
photos in here once in a while you're
there so job what'd you think of the
movie buddy I like this a lot I mean you
know I have you liked it more than the
first do you like it more than the
second is it better than those I don't
really care have to make it you have to
rank it see the thing for me is I think
this is a really consistent franchise
overall that has taken its element like
I thought the first one had a really
strong grip on storytelling on its
world-building on its visuals and all
that stuff it just was a solid
all-around fantasy epic family movie I
thought the second one built really well
on that and the third one just continues
that tradition for me like personally I
don't necessarily love any of these
films individually as much as I
appreciate the trilogy overall for
having so much consistency because yeah
I thought this was really emotionally
resonant it had the same level of there
are certain elements of the story that
are familiar but they did a lot of
things that had some weight or some
nuance or some clever decision-making
behind it and the animation is
breathtakingly beautiful as is the
imagination of the movie so yeah overall
I thought this was a really nice capper
and it was really nice to see them stick
the landing because there are so many
trilogies especially aimed at families
that just don't you know that run out I
would say that this is probably one of
the best trilogies I've ever seen yeah
in terms of tying everything up and
wrapping things up like if they did a
sequel I'd obviously be doesn't make
sense doesn't and terms of like tying up
hiccup storyline and toothless's
storyline as well beautifully done
beautifully done because a lot of this
story
is them having to learn to be apart as
well yes that's a big part of the theme
of this journey specifically in this one
is can they still move on and lead a
grand life without being together yeah
and also the hope for the hidden world
is yeah that you know even though you
make a great duo you don't define each
other's qualities yeah cuz that's a big
thing too there's a lot of coming-of-age
stuff in these movies and especially in
this third one I feel and you get a
great villain I feel like they're pretty
consistent I don't remember the first
the first villain was just the attitude
of everybody yeah yeah cuz the second
one you get Drago and then in this one
he had grimille which is a cool contrast
cuz Drago is like so laconic and just so
scary and he's just like half his
dialogue is him screaming and grimille
is very calm yeah yeah it looks like a
combination of Dracula next one seed out
he's just like calm and sinister but
he's really smart and intelligent as a
hunter and stuff like that and I thought
you know in a time where we get a lot of
big crazy villains I've pretty much
liked what they've done with their
villains too you know they make the
stakes pretty high they make the
characters pretty vivid yeah and I think
Riven was great well they do a great job
at giving us this immediate plot thank
at first kind of registers I think about
it 30 to 40 minutes in new and the
grimille storyline was really kicking in
I was thinking to myself like oh is this
have a good dude because I heard it's
the last one everyone has the last one
like oh so it's just something like cool
oh we got a new dragon hunter villain
and then you see how this story line is
what ultimately leads our characters our
two main characters toothless and hiccup
down to the most important and personal
finale of their lives yeah which I
thought was cool because you get kind of
just a really cool part three with this
new villain but you also get something
that's much deeper and much more nuanced
by the time he gets like the last half
hour of this movie it was because of
that grimille storyline as well yeah and
their willingness to let the franchise
grow over time too because part of this
movie involves them leaving their home
in search of someplace else because of
this imposed
Birk yeah there every movie has that if
this is Burke and we got dragons oh yeah
that's part of what I respect about this
I for a brief second I flashed to the
movie glass for some reason because you
know kind of just they all spend that
time in the mental husband's aren't real
when the movie starts I really like how
part two and three always reintroduce
and treat it as this is a new movie yeah
this is a new story as opposed to just
throwing you into something without
really setting up or caring about the
structure and I feel like sometimes with
part threes they lose sight of that as
well taken for granted like oh you see
this you're our franchise and they do a
good job of taking into logical accounts
of sort of things like you were talking
about the car ride back of when they
have all these dragons at Burke you know
how are they gonna sustain this but that
becomes a big part of the debate and
that's what leads the whole story is we
have so many freaking dragon knows about
us we're vulnerable yeah this is
actually this is threatening for us even
though we have all the dragons most of
the world doesn't like dragons you know
or understand mm-hmm and also you know
that I think with the toothless
storyline this was some of the best
stuff ever because yeah there are
certain sequences in here especially
with toothless and as a tease in the
trailer with a light fury they just
remind me of my cats because I got what
do I care and there's certain scenes in
here where it is pure visual
storytelling where it's only the
animation telling the story like no
dialogue yeah they're just watching
things happen off of body language or
flight sequences or interaction just
with toothless in the life here your
other dragons that are just pure visual
storytelling and I feel like when you're
doing animation and not relying on is my
one complaint I have one complaint with
this movie is I felt like a lot of the
jokes didn't really land now that how to
change me has ever been about the jokes
but I kind of always sort of felt that
with most animation films it's like yeah
the jokes are kind of just whatever
there's a few jokes here they're really
funny but most of them I
I really didn't land yeah well there's
like a kind of obvious switch out with
TJ Miller and I feel like T James a guy
who tried sounding like TJ Miller or
something you know so I'm like that
sounds like an impersonation of TJ
Miller and I feel like TJ Miller brings
a lot of improv and a lot of like they
had like TJ Miller s Klein's for him to
say but that was because they made that
character a bit more focal I thought
that was kind of an illustration of the
fact that yeah the comedy isn't as much
on point in this movie but that's kind
of the only area and going back to what
you mentioned before this did something
that I think a lot of animated films
don't do so much anymore that I really
loved which is just giving prolonged
sequences over to the visual
storytelling into the animation there's
a beautiful like sky dance sequence
between two the Dragons in this movie
that just reminded me of something much
older where if film takes a break from
the plot to just showcase how beautiful
animation can make a sequence and yeah I
mean especially after we come off of
films like spider-verse and lego movie 2
which are both great films but very
different I feel like with animation
movies a lot now it's a lot of jokes
really fast paced you know you revisited
How to Train Your Dragon 2 or as I
haven't seen that in so many years and
so when I watch it I was like oh yeah
this is actually a much more slower
paced that's not slow but it takes its
time a lot more than the other animated
movies do now to me these feel like epic
fantasies that have like an animated
family edge on them rather than an
animated family movie that has some
elements of an epic fantasy like the way
the stories unfold the way the stakes
are they're not overly grim but there is
some heavy stuff in there and there are
some challenging lessons for hiccup and
toothless to learn especially in this
movie because a lot of the central
conflict is about their relationship
yeah and about growing up and I feel
like it's there's a storyline yeah for
in terms of trilogy this is one of the
best composed trilogies you ever put
together this ain't some like Dark
Knight Rises oh this is a perfect
closing chapter it's pretty cool they
managed to make three consistently
important films to one another yeah so
yeah couldn't them proud of the movie
man they're like they should be really
proud it's an amazing accomplishment
like I'm with you I'm not in love with
each one of them as individuals but as a
trilogy it's like man I respect the hell
out of this but yeah definitely and the
fact they're letting it be here and now
this is done yeah and yeah I mean hats
off the voice cast is great the
animation is breathtaking the 3ds really
good it's just a great capper to this
franchise for me so I recommend it well
guys what did you think of How to Train
Your Dragon the hidden world do you want
to see a part four do you want to ruin
this perfect trilogy with another
installment leave it in the comments
below and as always you can subscribe to
the reject nation hit that notification
mail to get notified every time a review
or a video is out and don't forget to
follow us on the siddhart as dad would
love to have you join us over there
people peace